well first things first congratulations
on a year thank you I mean it doesn't
even seem like it's been a year I know
when you first started and now today I
feel like that we've got so much more to
talk about and so many talk shows don't
even last you here but you all are here
you got an Emmy nomination can you
believe that all of this has happened in
just this short time it feels like so
tiny amount of time I'm like it doesn't
even feel like we got here and they're
like it's been a year and I looked at
them in a really excited about the
n-double-a-cp image each got one taking
mine and putting it on the man because
there are so many bombshells that happen
at the read table you guys were just
talking about Ayesha curry Queen Latifah
said you will never get a day to be want
to know too much people business okay
you know but I thought if I was a sit at
a bread table you know they'd probably
be whoo Jada Jada might get too much
truth is it about this team when people
come and sit here with that magic sauce
and just makes people say that I'm gonna
spill it well I guess I don't think it's
not even so much cuz that's never our
intention saying we just always want to
have just real conversations and so I
think it's we're in the conversation
with you right yeah yeah we're we're
we were sharing our stories we're
sharing our experiences and it's just
about commune you know we're just
communing and I think when you see
someone else being vulnerable it makes
you feel like you can be vulnerable so
when you know most people be super
nervous and you know that's kind of a
thing when they come but when it's
always yeah exactly it's always when
they see us be vulnerable then they're
like oh okay it's it's okay to be gonna
save space for going on okay it's
interesting when you talk about taking
care of people because one of the most
anticipated episodes was I want to give
you the opportunity to tell your truth
but I want you to tell it through the
lens of what your part has been and I
just thought as a woman and a woman of
color it was so powerful to me to see
you all standing the gap
when there was so much vitriol coming
from everywhere it really was a powerful
did you all feel that too and how she
doing good oh just once again just
giving that opportunity for her to tell
her stories you know that's all all
anybody ever wants so we just felt
really happy to give her that
opportunity could we do a follow-up
because there are still people who want
to know like I really felt like a world
was stepping into a woman stepping into
her good point for us as women to be
able to recognize when there's a young
girl who just needs a little assistance
and ushering it right right and we've
all been there you know
so as grown women just kind of going
okay yeah what happened and here's a
little guided navigation ships you know
that's all a part of growing up okay and
so she's doing she's doing really well
as she learned a lot yeah besides Queen
Latifah who do we want at the table next
you know I never really I say cuz they
never you know but we do have a lot of
ideas but you know people have to want
to come yeah it's not something to be
honest with you we don't ask people a
lot really no because I feel usually
everything you - okay yeah it's
important for them to feel like they
have something that they wanted to say
and they you know they have a message
that they want to get out to the world
right like I said what Jordan she asked
that wasn't a cheek oh yeah that didn't
even get even more impressed oh yes a I
really feel like I need this ASA
yeah that was something she desires
something she wanted and that was not an
ass after all these episodes what was
the one that made you walk away from the
table
okay I need a minute I need a minute to
collect myself yeah there's a
domestic-violence is definitely the show
on addiction the show on forgiveness
yeah the show we also did about grief
and loss yeah yeah yeah the one about
domestic abuse specifically for me it
was like yeah I just might need to take
just a tiny break yeah little one yeah
is there one that took like the most out
of you filming like I think the grief
episode yeah he left me and I know
that's not true and it's a very selfish
way to think about it but I really did
believe that he was gonna be here for
the long run
all right just because I had just heard
that day before I hit the table that I
literally lost a friend so that that was
that was a tough one that was a tough
one the next rave table oh this one's
about poor not it's not like I you know
look down on people that use it because
you know it's been beneficial for me too
right
but how's it not a topic that you think
daughter mommy
and Jamie I mean do you have those
though that you like I don't know if I
can talk about this and is there a topic
that you say we're never going to touch
I don't know if there's a topic that we
would say we're never going to touch
we've kind of decided that we wanted to
kind of stay away from politics and
religion oh yeah definitely
yeah goes to speak a lot to spirituality
[Applause]
different I do have to say we were just
with will in London master Rikuo
what did Jada feel about the ponytail
what did she think about the pony she
liked the top not [ __ ] really um you
should rock the top Matt you should grow
out a top knot as well I can I'm telling
you man I'm telling you I was really
sexy by myself as the genie
and he told us that miss Jada loved the
topknot then he said being a genie made
him feel even sexy did you really love
the top box
I must say oh this is what I want okay
this is what I was saying I definitely
thought him as the genie was a really
nice look okay now whether I was into
the top specifically but when I'll say
it was really nice to see him you know
him in Aladdin period it just gave him
this real freedom yeah so much fun and I
think that I really her though I look at
will and I see freedom yeah exactly
he's gotten really really free I'm so
happy for him in this and this part of
his life but I could totally see that
while he was making this movie like the
making of the movie was so inspiring to
him and he was super inspired like in
the making and I usually it was just so
nice to see him that he just had fun can
I just ask you ladies really quick
Mother's Day just passed what did you
guys do how did you celebrate together
you actually went on a really nice
nature yeah yeah anyway because
everybody else was out of town town
Jaden was out of town gone yeah I'm back
home so willow she spent the day with me
doing so nice it was so nice it's such a
good time to get
it was just social a little meditation
we do it was a really nice day
well something you said to me stuck with
through something you said today stuck
with me and I'm gonna go call my mom cuz
you said she's my best friend but I
really ain't know her story and that
stuck with me so I'm going to call her
me like
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]